i have a saying that your food is your
flag
food can tell us where we come from and
who we are
[Music]
i'm a culinary historian historic
interpreter and the james beard
award-winning author of the cooking gene
the last thing people will give up as
they make journeys and migrations is
their food culture
you have to look at one particular dish
and then you can trace it back to its
origin story and they asked the question
why did my family make that food you
begin to get a picture
of how you're situated in a larger story
[Music]
this class is not a full-on cooking
school of african-american culinary
technique it's about new ways to express
our relationship to food through writing
through storytelling through genealogy
what you will learn is how to document
your own food story and have a greater
context for where we come from
go to the eldest people who are able to
tell you the stories that answer your
questions you're going to have a moment
where you close your eyes and you open
them and that entire table will be
surrounded by the people that populated
that person's life
you have to be willing to
go into the positive and negative
aspects of your family history and
journey
if you really want to do this work
we have to talk about traumatic stuff
history the concept of race
that potato famine that holocaust
that slave trade
that's only part of the puzzle
but in confronting the issues that come
off of that
we become better because we understand
what it took to get us here
what i'm trying to offer you is a little
bit of insight so you can do your own
journey through food to find the
ancestral wisdom in the kitchen that's
right for you
and if i can do it i hope that you will
as well
i hope that you will have the strength
to say that your story matters as much
as mine does
i'm michael twitty and this is
masterclass
[Music]
you